you were born and raised in los angeles
yeah yeah uh your parents
immigrants immigrants yeah from korea
from korea
now korea are they
were they supportive of your choice to
be an
actor no no no not at all
and and you know i understand why they
you know they emigrated to this country
you know they left all their friends and
and family behind
uh you know and sacrificed everything
ultimately so their kids
you know could could have a better life
not you know not for us to
do background on a web series you know
yeah
yeah so so they they were very against
it and uh
but when i booked my very first job i
was so excited about it i
i was sure that if i showed them it was
a commercial
okay it was a commercial for like the
chinese channel in los angeles
and i was i thought it was my big break
and i thought if i what was the
commercial for
i you know to this day i don't fully
know
i don't know i was told it was like a
liverpool something like that that's
supposed to give you more energy
yeah yeah and in the commercial i don't
have any lines but you know i i'm like i
act tired you know and then i wake up
and uh and i showed it to my mom and
like the first thing she said was
you have to quit
[Laughter]
you are a really bad actor
i think we should decide for ourselves
let's talk oh no you have it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for young
[Music]
your child